We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the middle of Sproul Plaza on the campus of UC Berkeley, it's a sculpture, 60,000 feet tall,
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在加州大学伯克利分校校园的斯普劳尔广场中央，有一座 60,000 英尺高的雕塑，
but don't feel bad if you've never noticed it before. I've had people come and look for it specifically and not find it. That makes me think, well maybe I should have made it a little bigger. Or maybe that's just the cost of making an invisible sculpture. I've kind of set myself up, aren't I? That's Mark Bressfen Kempen. His invisible sculpture is known to most as the free speech monument. It's actually called column of earth and air. It's a six inch circle of soil and the column of air above it,
但如果你以前从未注意到它，也不必感到难过。我曾让人专门去找它，结果却没找到。这让我觉得，也许我应该把它做得再大一点。或者，这可能就是创作一件隐形雕塑的代价。我算是给自己挖了个坑，不是吗？那是马克·布雷斯芬·肯彭。他的隐形雕塑在大多数人眼中被称为“言论自由纪念碑”。它实际上叫“大地与空气之柱”。它是一个六英寸的土壤圆圈，以及它上方的那一柱空气，
extending all the way to the limit of US controlled airspace hence the 60,000 feet. The column is marked by a six foot granite ring embedded flush into the concrete of the plaza, the inscription of the outer edge reads, this soil and the airspace extending above it shall not be part of any nation and shall not be subject to any entities jurisdiction.
一直延伸到美国领空的极限，所以才有 60,000 英尺高。这根柱子由一个嵌入广场混凝土中、与地面齐平的六英尺花岗岩环标记，外缘刻着：这片土地及其上方的领空不属于任何国家，也不受任何实体的管辖。
It's a sculpture that issues the traditional materials of wood, clay, or metal, and instead uses... Jurisdiction laws and politics is kind of material to work with. The free speech monument has both subtlety and grandeur and it's also just fun and thought provoking, a new way to consider jurisdictional space. Usually, spaces of jurisdiction you enter into. You cross into a country, you cross into a state,
这是一座摒弃了木材、粘土或金属等传统材料的雕塑，转而使用……管辖权法律和政治作为创作材料。言论自由纪念碑既有微妙之处，又有宏伟之感，而且它既有趣又发人深省，是一种考虑管辖空间的新方式。通常，管辖空间是你进入的地方。你进入一个国家，你进入一个州，
you move into somebody's private property, and I thought it would be interesting to kind of invert that and have a space that sort of moves through your body. And when you stand next to it today, 20 years after it was installed, you'd never suspect the drama that went on to get this granite circle placed in the ground on university property. I was kind of thrown into a little bit of a harness nest that I wasn't prepared for at
你进入某人的私人领地，而我认为如果能将其反转过来，创造一个能穿过你身体的空间，那会很有趣。今天，在它落成 20 年后，当你站在它旁边时，你永远不会想到为了让这个花岗岩圆环放置在大学土地上所经历的波折。我当时被卷入了一个我完全没有准备好的马蜂窝里。
all. Here's what happened. The free speech monument was born out of an open design competition to commemorate the 25th anniversary of the start of the free speech movement. A bunch of professors, ex-professors, they call themselves the Berkeley art project. Put this competition together separate from the university. They did it as not autonomous group because they knew if they tried to go through the university to commemorate the free speech movement, it would go nowhere because at the time the university did not want to commemorate the free speech movement in any way shape or form. The free speech movement started in the fall of 1964 when students set up a table in Sproul
事情是这样的。言论自由纪念碑源于一场公开设计竞赛，旨在纪念“言论自由运动”开始 25 周年。一群教授和前教授，他们自称为“伯克利艺术项目”，在大学之外组织了这场竞赛。他们作为一个非自治团体进行这项工作，因为他们知道，如果他们试图通过大学来纪念言论自由运动，那将一事无成，因为当时大学不想以任何形式纪念言论自由运动。言论自由运动始于 1964 年秋天，当时学生们在斯普劳尔广场摆了一张桌子，
Plaza to recruit for an off-campus civil rights group. This was against school policy at the time. And everything escalated from there. The following months were marked by sit-ins and strikes and arrest. It was a pivotal moment that defined what we think of as the 60s, so a monument seems appropriate. So anyway, it's 1989, the call-in-out hundreds of designs were considered. So close to 300 entries from all over the country, they weeded that down to five. And there was this open period of public discussion and voting that included the public and art critics and all kinds of people outside of the Berkeley Art Project that
为校外的民权组织招募成员。这在当时违反了学校政策。此后一切都升级了。接下来的几个月里，静坐、罢工和逮捕事件不断。这是一个决定性的时刻，定义了我们所认为的 60 年代，所以建立一座纪念碑似乎很合适。总之，那是 1989 年，征集活动开始了，数百个设计方案被考虑。近 300 份来自全国各地的参赛作品，他们筛选出了五个。随后有一个公开讨论和投票的阶段，包括公众、艺术评论家以及伯克利艺术项目之外的各种人士，
eventually selected Mark Bressvin Kempens column of Earth and air as the free speech monument. Democracy doesn't always work with art though so I'm glad that it worked out this time. The people who had put the project together wanted to give the winning entry to the university as a gift. And then, of course, the university did not want to accept it as a gift and did everything that they could not do. And the reason for the reluctance is that a lot of the Berkeley Art Project Group, the ones commissioning the monument,
最终选择了马克·布雷斯芬·肯彭的“大地与空气之柱”作为言论自由纪念碑。不过，民主并不总是适用于艺术，所以我很高兴这次成功了。组织该项目的人想把获奖作品作为礼物送给大学。当然，大学不想接受这份礼物，并尽其所能拒绝。他们之所以不情愿，是因为伯克利艺术项目组的许多人，即委托建造这座纪念碑的人，
and the higher ups at the university, were the same people who were in the fight 25 years before. And they were still very upset about it. They still had very hurt feelings. So UC Berkeley did not want to memorialize the free speech movement in general. And they hated this piece in particular. Yeah, so they did everything in their power
和大学的高层，正是 25 年前那场斗争中的同一批人。他们对此仍然感到非常愤怒。他们仍然怀有很深的怨恨。因此，加州大学伯克利分校不想纪念言论自由运动，他们特别讨厌这件作品。是的，所以他们竭尽全力
to not accept this gift. Which is kind of hard to do and still seem like a good guy. And after this big public selection process, they didn't have too much of a choice. So the university decided to accept the sculpture under one condition. They said, OK, we'll accept this commemoration
不接受这份礼物。这很难做到，同时还要表现得像个好人。在经过这次大规模的公开评选过程后，他们没有太多选择。于是，大学决定在满足一个条件的情况下接受这座雕塑。他们说，好吧，我们会接受这个纪念活动，
to free speech as long as the press release that goes out does not contain any reference to the free speech movement. That's right. The free speech monument was censored. And the unintended side effect is that it made a piece of conceptual art conceptually better. Ironically it wasn't just the university administration that had a problem with the column of Earth and Air.
只要发布的新闻稿中不包含任何关于“言论自由运动”的提及。没错。言论自由纪念碑被审查了。而意想不到的副作用是，它使这件概念艺术作品在概念上变得更好了。讽刺的是，不仅仅是大学管理层对“大地与空气之柱”有意见。
A couple of the early free speech movement leaders expressed their misgivings about the monument as well. I remember having a conversation with Mario Savio. He didn't like the piece at all. Not to put words in his mouth, but I did get the impression that he wanted something that was a little bit more specific to the free speech movement in the 60s and I specifically didn't want to do that. It seemed more relevant to me to use a real person
一些早期的言论自由运动领导人也表达了他们对这座纪念碑的疑虑。我记得曾与马里奥·萨维奥交谈过。他一点也不喜欢这件作品。不是要替他代言，但我确实感觉到他想要一些更具体地指向 60 年代言论自由运动的东西，而我特意不想那样做。对我来说，用一个真实的人在当下就他们深感关切的事情自由发言，作为言论自由的纪念碑，比雕像之类的东西更有意义。
speaking freely about something that they felt strongly about at that moment as a monument to free speech rather than a statue or something like that. The piece itself remains unfinished. The goal was to completely liberate this six inch circle of soil at the center from any jurisdiction and to do that. It would have to go through all the jurisdictions, you know, the private property owners, the board of regions, the city of Berkeley, County of Alameda, the state. There would have to be an active Congress. You'd also have to get international treaties because you don't want France coming in and taking that little piece of land.
这件作品本身仍然未完成。目标是彻底将中心这个六英寸的土壤圆圈从任何管辖权中解放出来，要做到这一点，它必须经过所有的管辖区，你知道，私人业主、董事会、伯克利市、阿拉米达县、州政府。还需要国会采取行动。你还得获得国际条约，因为你不想让法国进来占领那一小块土地。
So, you know, it'll probably never be completely finished. After several attempts, he made it only to the city jurisdiction level before getting thwarted. And now, 20 years after it was installed, I'm standing in a noisy sprout plaza with Mark Bressfinn-Kempin and we run our hands through the column of air. And even though the jurisdiction freeze zone was never formalized, I asked him if he feels something when he passes through the invisible column. Yeah, I do. Yeah, I feel like I can feel the space, you know. I grew up in Utah, and I would go to Southern Utah a lot in the four corners area. That's the only place the United States where four states come together at one point. I remember very specifically jumping from state to state, from Arizona, to Colorado, to Utah.
所以，你知道，它可能永远不会真正完成。经过几次尝试，他只达到了城市管辖权层面就受阻了。现在，在它落成 20 年后，我正站在嘈杂的斯普劳尔广场上，和马克·布雷斯芬·肯彭在一起，我们把手伸进空气柱中。尽管管辖权自由区从未正式化，但我问他，当他穿过这根隐形柱子时，是否有什么感觉。是的，我有。是的，我觉得我能感觉到那个空间，你知道。我在犹他州长大，经常去犹他州南部的四角地区。那是美国唯一四个州交汇于一点的地方。我记得非常清楚，我从一个州跳到另一个州，从亚利桑那州，到科罗拉多州，到犹他州，
To New Mexico, it's also fun to lie down, spread eagle, and all four states at once. And really having a visceral feeling about that invisible line, obviously it's just psychological. But those spaces are very real. I mean, you commit certain acts in one space, and you can do it. You can make certain acts in another space,
到新墨西哥州，躺下来，四肢张开，同时横跨四个州也很有趣。那种对隐形边界的直观感受非常强烈，显然这只是心理上的。但这些空间是非常真实的。我的意思是，你在一个空间里犯下某些行为，你可以这样做。你在另一个空间里做出某些行为，
and you might be killed. So even though they're imaginary, just certain extent they're very real. 99% Invisible was produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW 91.7 in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architect San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. You could find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars because that's my name, but you can always just find the show online at 99%invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可能会被杀。所以，尽管它们是想象出来的，但在某种程度上它们是非常真实的。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持，用创造力创造改变。这是旧金山 KALW 91.7、美国建筑师协会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞这个节目。我在 Twitter 上使用 @RomanMars，因为那是我的名字，但你总是可以在 99%invisible.org 在线找到这个节目。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。